Tiger and Lily were enemies.
If Tiger hissed, Lily hissed.
If Lily got to the food first, Tiger hissed.
If Tiger got to the food first, Lily hissed.
If Tiger played with the toy, Lily hissed.
If Lily played with the toy, Tiger hissed.
If Lily was fast asleep, Tiger had great fun waking her up.
Sometimes Tiger was fast asleep.
Lily had great fun waking him up.
If Tiger sat in a lap first, Lily hissed.
If Lily sat in a lap first, Tiger hissed.
If the back door opened, they raced to get outside.
If Lily got there first, Tiger hissed.
If Tiger got there first, Lily hissed.
But something different happened when no one was around.
Tiger and Lily were the best of friends.